the original deal was that me and my
boyfriend were looking for a house we
couldn't get approved for a house by
itself so we bought a modular home and
my grandma said oh you can put it on my
property um and then you guys can
eventually when you can buy the property
and keep it in the family name okay so
when you are talking about your finances
with your boyfriend you're using a lot
of like we statements we're doing this
our debt all of it so just doing this
for as long as we have um when you are
not legally
married M there is not an
hours we conversation like these there's
going to be two separate Lanes here and
I know that's going to be difficult for
you to kind of untangle in your head
because it has been so unified but what
ends up happening is is that you combine
emotionally acting like you're married
combining accounts uh paying on each
other's debt all of it without any legal
representation no legal documents here